the coronavirus
and the onslaught
that has been foisted upon the american
people and indeed the world has really
laid bare
some very sinister aspects of the
republican party
that they have completely jettisoned any
concern for the american people and the
health and welfare
of them
even their constituents
this
beating the drum of self-reliance
and pulling yourself up by your
bootstraps and personal responsibility
while
romantic to republicans
doesn't play when we're talking about an
invisible virus
that can spread
without anybody knowing it
so it's not like a helmet law when you
ride a motorcycle
that if you crack your head open and
spill your brains onto the interstate
you're only hurting yourself
they can't make that argument
ein rand nonsense only goes so far
but when you try to practically apply
those ideals
to a pandemic
they fail
let's talk about ted cruz and an
appearance he made on fox news on
hannity's show
really extolling the virtues of no
mandates for anything
watch this remarkable
bs
in a time of crisis
people's character is revealed and and
the character of democrats whether it is
joe biden whether it is andrew cuomo
whether it is bill de blasio whether it
is newsome
the character from their perspective
that they do not respect your liberty
they do not respect your right to make
your choices about your health care
about your children about your lives
my views were very simple there should
be no mandates zero concerning covid
that means no mass mandates regardless
of your vaccination status that means no
ma no vaccine mandates
that means no vaccine passports and i've
introduced legislation a bill to ban
vaccine passports this week i'm
introducing a bill to ban vaccine
mandates and this will i'm a week i'm
introducing a bill to end mass mandates
now that doesn't mean as the media likes
to characterize
that i'm opposed to vaccines i actually
think vaccines are terrific i've taken
the vaccine my family's taken the
vaccine but i believe in individual
choice individual responsibility you can
make the choice for your family these
mandates are coming and as you noted a
few minutes ago talking about dr fauci
what they're talking about
is political it's not tied to the
science it is political now
ted cruz
because of you
because of your
colleagues
your republican goofball colleagues who
have made this political and it is
remarkable to me
senator cruz that you list all of these
people that you act like are
are not concerned about americans
liberty or lives or or health or welfare
or well-being and it's all democrats
you named no one on your side the bomb
throwers
the jim jordans
the the the
holly from missouri
the encouragers of insurrectionists you
didn't name anybody there
but to to poopoo mandates mask mandates
that absolutely curb the transmission of
the virus without a doubt fact
to to in one breath talk about that you
got the vaccine and it's it's safe and
it's good but also say but no one should
be forced to get it
the reason we're in a position to even
talk about having that to mandate
vaccines is because you have
vilified
and demonized
the getting of the vaccine so much so
that there are millions of americans
many of whom are in a very very peculiar
area of the country where this kind of
recalcitrance is common in the south
and you've you've ginned up fear
all couched in personal responsibility
all all couched in
my liberty
it is nonsense
and it is nonsense because if you go to
the grocery store and you've refused to
get the vaccine and you're asymptomatic
for the coronavirus
and you pass it on to someone who is
who is immunocompromised
and unable for valid medical reasons to
get the vaccine and you give them
coveton they die
your rights
do not exceed do not extend beyond
where you can swing your arm have you
heard that before ted cruz
this is dangerous this is disgusting and
this is
political that's all this is
from ted cruz
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is you
don't have to guess which mattress do i
need which one will be good for me you
take their famous sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you i took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what i needed i often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and i've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so
don't get stuck with something that's
not perfect for you and all helix
mattresses come with a 10-year warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within 100 days if you don't
love it but i think you will all of my
viewers will get up to 200 off your
order and you'll get two super premium
pillows for free when you go to the link
right underneath this video